hey everyone welcome back and let's
write some more neat code today so today
let's solve the problem max area of an
island this is actually very similar to
another problem that we have solved
called number of islands it's pretty
much the same general algorithm but
we're returning a slightly different
result rather than counting the number
of islands we're actually going through
every island and figuring out which one
of them has the max area and then we're
going to return the max area of any of
these islands so the general idea is the
same we're given a 2d grid where zeros
represent water as you can see they're
blue and ones represent land and of
course an island is going to be you know
consecutive one values that are
connected either horizontally right like
from the left and right side or
vertically so up and down you know two
cells that are connected diagonally
don't really count so you know if i add
one here
uh you know if this was a one it would
still uh basically this and this are not
connected they're not an island they're
separately an island this is a separate
island this is a separate island this is
a separate island and this is a separate
island so there's really two parts to
this algorithm
first you need to be able to get the
area of any given island and you can do
that with your graph algorithm of choice
i prefer doing it with the dfs depth
first search so understanding debt for
search is a prerequisite for this
problem and the good thing is if you do
have a good understanding of dfs then
this problem is pretty easy all you
really have to do is kind of understand
how dfs fits into the context of this
problem and in this case it's actually
pretty simple so i'll be walking through
dfs and then walking through how we can
apply that to this algorithm so running
dfs on an island such as this one so
suppose you know we start here we wanna
we see that it's a one value right that
means it's an island but is the area of
this island just one itself or are there
other cells connected to it that are
also land and if there are we want to
run dfs in all directions to basically
count how many cells are connected so
the way dfs works is we're going to run
dfs above which we see is out of bounds
so dfs is a recursive algorithm and
since up above we're out of bounds the
dfs is going to return zero basically
telling us that the area of the island
in the above direction is zero similarly
on the left and right side it's not out
of bounds but this is water so it
doesn't count as an island but of course
when we go down we see we reach a one
and this one has not been visited so far
so again uh we reach another one value
cell and again recursively we're going
to run dfs in all four directions so
going to the left which is water so
don't do anything there going down which
is also water don't do anything we're
also going to go up above actually even
though we've already visited that cell
which is kind of a problem we don't want
to have to go and run dfs recursively on
a cell that we've already visited so the
way in dfs to get around that is to have
you know some kind of data structure we
can call it visit it's going to be a
hash set so
using this hash set we can kind of mark
the positions that we've already visited
so that we don't end up revisiting them
that will help us with the time
complexity of this problem and the last
direction from here is to go right where
we see that yes there's an island so uh
you know we we run dfs from this
position as well we look up nothing
there down nothing there left we've
already visited that right side is
unvisited so that's the last cell
there's you know in all other directions
there's nothing else so after running
dfs on this island what did we get what
do we want our dfs to return well of
course we want to know the area of every
one of these islands right that's the
only reason we're even running dfs so
dfs from this island should return the
value 4 because that's the area of this
island now it probably makes sense how
dfs fits into this problem once you get
good at writing dfs dfs becomes trivial
all we have to do is figure out how to
apply it to this problem and it's pretty
simple in our case we're going to run
dfs on every single island and then you
know keep track of which one of these
has the maximum area as you can see this
one has the maximum area of six so we're
going to end up returning six in this
problem now how are we gonna run dfs on
every single island the easiest way to
do it since we don't know which cells
are zero and which ones are one until we
actually look at every single individual
cell that's exactly what we're gonna
have to do we're gonna start at the top
left look at every single cell if we see
a one value we're gonna run dfs on it
and figure out the area of that island
if we don't see a one value we're going
to skip it so we're going to have by the
end of it we're going to have visited
every single position and run dfs on
every island so we will know which one
is the maximum the only problem is what
if we run dfs on this position and then
we run dfs on this position won't we get
the same exact area won't we run dfs on
the same island twice well no and that's
the reason we are using our visit set
because we don't want to run dfs on an
island multiple times so at this point
you can probably see that the time
complexity of this problem since in the
worst case we're really only going to be
visiting each cell you know a constant
number of times it's not going to be you
know exponential or anything the time
complexity is going to be the size of
the entire grid which
we're given is m by n so in that case
the overall time complexity is going to
be m times n
and that's also going to be the memory
complexity because remember we are
having a hash set which could
in the worst case contain every single
cell in the grid
and of course dfs is recursive so
there's a call stack associated with it
but uh this is going to be the memory
bottleneck the hash set so the time and
space complexity is going to be big o m
times n that's enough for us to now jump
into the code okay so now let's write
the code if you've seen any of my graph
videos you probably know i like to solve
all these problems in a very formulaic
way the first thing i like to do is just
get the dimensions of the grid because
usually it comes in handy so let's get
the number of columns and the number of
rows in the entire grid the only other
data structure we're going to be needing
is the visit hash set so let's declare
that above and now we want to write our
recursive dfs function i like to just
write the dfs inside of our root
function because in that case we won't
have to pass in every single parameter
all we are going to be passing in is the
position that we're going to be visiting
so rc is going to be the row column that
we are running dfs on we won't have to
pass in the visit or the grid itself and
with dfs we always want to handle the
base case first with all recursive
functions
one base case is if we go out of bounds
how do we determine that well if rho is
less than zero or a row is too big it'll
be too big if it's exactly equal to the
number of rows that we have uh or you
know the same thing with the column if
it's less than zero or it's equal to the
number of columns and there's two other
cases remember one is if we reach water
we don't want to run dfs on water so if
the grid column position is equal to
zero and last but not least we don't
want to revisit the same position so if
the row column pair is already inserted
in our visit hash set then we don't want
to revisit it so in all of these cases
what do we want to return well remember
our dfs is trying to calculate the area
of every island in this case we didn't
find an island so we want to return zero
and after that don't forget to add
this row column pair to our hash set to
indicate that it has been visited and
after we do that we want to calculate
the area of uh this position right of
this island how are we going to do that
well the current cell that we're at is
going to count as one of the area values
and the other
positions we can pretty much run dfs on
all four directions right so let's call
dfs i'm passing in how about row plus
one uh column right and we can actually
just copy and paste this four times so
let's do that this can also be done with
like a for loop to go through all four
directions but i just prefer writing it
out it's not too much code and it's
pretty easy so we just want to replace
these with all four directions so
another direction is row minus one
another direction will be
column plus one and another direction
will be column
minus one so that's all four directions
so each of these dfs's is calculating
the area of the remaining portion of the
island in each of these four directions
then we're adding all four of them up
including the one cell that we are
currently visiting right now and once
we've added all those up all we really
need to do is return it because that's
what our dfs is trying to do just return
the area of the island if it hasn't
already been visited so now that we've
written our dfs we've pretty much solved
the entire problem all we really have to
do is iterate over uh the entire grid
which we can do just like this nested
for loops going through every row going
through every single column in the grid
and actually let's maintain a single
variable let's call it area or you could
call it the result initially it's going
to be set to zero right this is the max
area that we're maintaining
every single time we call our dfs we
want to potentially update the area if
it's greater than the current area so
we're going to take the max of the
current area and the max
of the dfs call that we're going to be
doing on the row column pair that we're
currently iterating through and once
that is done we will have the max area
so all we have to do is return it and
last let's run this code and make sure
that it works okay i was very dumb uh we
forgot to add the plus sign to each of
these i don't know how i forgot that but
let's not forget it so yeah so in case
it wasn't clear all we're doing is
adding all four of these together adding
it to the one as well so now let's run
it to make sure that it works and as you
can see on the left yes it works and
it's about as efficient as we can get
for this problem i will say that one
other optimization you can do is you
don't actually need an external visit
set you can actually just use the grid
itself to determine if you've visited a
position or not but we're not guaranteed
that we can write over the input grid so
i don't think it's a big deal to use a
hash set i guess you could clarify with
your interviewer if you really want to
but it's just a small optimization that
isn't a big deal in my opinion but i
really hope that this was helpful if it
was please like and subscribe it really
supports the channel a lot consider
checking out my patreon if you'd like to
further support the channel and
hopefully i'll see you pretty soon
thanks for watching